structures can be thought of as file
cabinets the foul Covenant has folders
that contain information to refer to a
folder in the cabinet you would call by
the word associated with it for example
that the file cabinet was called data we
would type data name to refer to the
folder in which we are going to store
some data here we are storing the word
Mike in Dayton a we can add as many
folders to this file cabinet as we want
just by typing the name of the file
cabinet data followed by the dot symbol
and then the word we want to associate
with the folder this word is referred to
as the field the voters themselves can
contain any array they can be an array
of numbers or cells or even more
structures typing data llego equals red
lego stores a red lego into the folder
called lego
[Music]
these Apple equals pioneer max as
another folder named Apple and stores a
pioneer back inside it just like other
arrays arrays of structures can have
multiple elements adding a second
element is like adding an extra file
cabinet we can do this by typing data
parentheses 1 comma 2 dot name equals
Colin when this is done every folder
that was defined for the first structure
is copied over to the second structure
there will already be three folders in
this file cabinet the folders for Apple
and Lego will be empty until we define
them if we add a new folder to either
element of the structure it will be
added to close
[Music]